female: Welcome to today's
Authors @GoogleTalks.
I have the pleasure of introducing today's guest
who is a prize winning journalist,
bestselling novelist and
prolific writer in contemporary Jewish--
She has authored three bestselling novels
including "The Red Tent",
"Good Harbor",
and "The Last Days of Dogtown."
On a more personal note
she is my fellow Washu alum
and your Massachusetts neighbor.
She is here today to speak with
us about her most recent work,
"Day after Night"
We're in for a real treat.
Please welcome Anita Diamant.
[applause]
Anita: Hi, thanks for taking time
out of your day,
or I guess you want to thank me
for the legitimate opportunity to play hooky.
Although I was thinking of Google
as not a place
anybody wants to play hooky
from in hindsight.
[Laughter]
Anita: As a consumer
and user of Google,
I feel that I belong here on behalf
of everybody who Google's as a verb.
I mean my 84 year old mother
knows what Google as a verb.
And when that happened I knew
the world had changed forever, so.
[laughter]
And it's also nice to be here
in Massachusetts.
I got to visit the New York mother ship;
although that's not the mother ship
is it actually.
But our New York
office which was,
it took a half an hour
just to walk through it.
So it's great to be here.
And I'm gonna talk to you
about my most recent novel
which was published in September.
I'm gonna talk about
how I came to write it,
a little bit about the research.
I'll read just a short passage,
and then hopefully we can do more
of a conversation with a little Q & A.
I'm not sure anybody,
has anybody read this yet?
Only one person and she's
already [Inaudible].
Yeah! Ok, so I won't --
well there won't be any spoilers.
No spoilers.
I wrote this book --
the way I came to find out about
the story that this novel tells
is that my daughter who
was spending a semester in Israel
when she was 15 years old
on a high-school program.
And she lived in Jerusalem,
and she studied math and English
and social studies and everything else
as she would have in her high-school
here in Newton.
But she also did a year course,
a semester course on the history of Israel-
from prehistory through modern times.
So my husband and I went on the parents' trip
which was our first trip to Israel.
This was 19-,
it was 2000, 2001.
And we followed them around on
their field trips basically for a week-
we got on and off the bus.
We went with them to --
all over the state of Israel.
By the time we got there,
they were studying the founding of
the state of Israel so we were inabout--
we were in the 1940's by then--
late 1940's and a little before that.
End of WWII, prehistory,
then the founding of the state.
So we got on and off the bus in Tel Aviv
where there had been a big rally
when the announcement came that the United
Nations had acknowledged the state of Israel
as a real state.
And we were in prisons
and we were in battlefields.
And at one point we got off the bus
in a place called Atlit
which nobody had ever heard of--
sort of in the middle of nowhere,
a couple of miles south of Haifa
which is a beautiful coast city.
And it's actually Boston's sister city,
it looks more like San Francisco than,
than Boston.
It's very hilly,
but it's an ocean, sea side town.
So we got out and we found
ourselves in what was
essentially a prison,
it looked like a prison camp.
It was a very bare-bones kind of place.
It was actually--
it's a place that kids go a lot,
and Israeli kids go to learn
this particular chapter in Israeli history.
It's a little bit like old Sturbridge village
or Plymouth plantation or Williamsburg
if you've been to any of those places--
except there's no snack bar,
there's no restaurant,
there's barely a bathroom,
it was very, very basic.
And it had been in service,
and the reason we were there
is that in the 1940's,
the British who had the mandate
in Palestine--
they were given
by the United Nations to run,
to administer Palestine--
were in charge.
And there were,
there was a quota on the number of Jewish
immigrants allowed into the land
and when people broke the law and
came in without the requisite papers,
they were thrown in this prison in Atlit.
And in 1944 - 1945
right after WWII,
immigrants from Europe,
immigrants from the holocaust,
survivors got to the land of Israel.
The British nabbed them off the
boats and threw them into Atlit
which is a place surrounded
by barbed wire fences.
So to go from-- some of these people who
had been survivors in concentration camps
to get thrown into--
what looked like from the outside anyway--
another concentration camp was
profoundly traumatic and frightening.
Once they got inside,
they learned pretty quickly that
they weren't going to be killed,
that they were going to be fed
and that there were in fact
members of the Jewish community
who lived in Palestine called the Yishu,
who were there volunteering
and working with the local authorities
to connect them with the head
family members in the land,
to make sure that they had
medical attention and food,
and but it was kind of a weird limbo place.
So we got off the bus,
we learned all of this,
this little chapter
of Israeli history,
American-Jewish history,
world history that certainly nobody
on our bus had ever heard about.
And we had this terrific guy who was also
the principal of my daughter's program.
And he told us this story about
how in 1945, in October of 1945,
the Palmach, which was the fighting arm
of the Jewish community there,
broke everybody out of the camp
because they were threatening
to send people back to Iraq
in particular where they would have been killed.
And they rescued 200 people, marched them
up the mountains and got away with it.
So here's your [inaudible] rescue which
is-- which Yitzhak Rabin was part of,
who was the past prime minister of Israel.
So it was a great story,
and I'm sitting there thinking to myself,
'What a great novel.'
And that was in 2000,
but I really was not in a big rush
to write this novel
because I knew it was gonna be heavy.
I'd need to spend--
it takes me about 3 years
from the beginning of starting
to do the serious research
and writing and rewriting and rewriting
and rewriting until a book comes out.
To spend 3 years really thinking
about the holocaust,
thinking about what life must
have been like for people after the war
trying to find a new life in a new place
where everything was unfamiliar
to them-- the land, the climate,
everybody around them.
People who were traumatized
in a million different ways.
So I wrote three other novels,
books including two novels
and a non-fiction book.
But this story was sort of sitting
at the back of my shoulder and tapping me
and I didn't want anyone else
to get to it before I did,
so there was that element.
So about four years ago,
I wrote a brief proposal, got a contract
and started working on this book.
And I went back to Atlit,
back to Israel a couple of times.
Interviewed people there,
and I'll tell you a little bit more about that.
I'm gonna read you the prologue
and ask you not to follow along
in your books.
Go back to being a little kid on your parent's lap
which is how everybody I think
who loves books
and reading learns to love books and reading.
It's very short, it's only three pages.
So this is the prologue to
"Day after Night".
[clears her throat.]
"1945, August.
The nightmares made
their rounds hours ago.
The tossing and whimpering are over.
Even the insomniacs have settled down.
The 20 restless bodies rest,
and faces aged by grief hunger
and doubt relax
to reveal the beauty and the pity
of their youth.
Not one of the women in barrack C is 21,
but all of them are orphans.
Their cheeks press against
small military issue pillows
that smell of disinfectant.
Lumpy and flat from long service
under heavier heads,
they bear no resemblance
to the goose down clouds
that many of them enjoyed in childhood.
And yet the girls burrow
into them with perfect contentment,
embracing them like teddy bears.
There were no pillows for them
in the other barracks.
No one gives a pillow to an animal.
The British built Atlit in 1938
to house their own troops.
It was one in a group of bases,
garages and storage units
on a coastal plain a few miles
south of Haifa.
But at the end of the World War,
as European Jews began making
their way to the ancestral homeland
in violation of international
political agreements,
the mandate in Palestine
became messier.
Which how it came to pass the Atlit
was turned into a prison,
or in the language of command,
a detention center
for refugees
without permissory papers.
The English arrested thousands
as illegal immigrants,
sent most of them to Atlit,
but quickly set them free
like fish too small to fry.
It was a perfectly forgettable compound
composed of wooden barracks and buildings
set out in rows on a scant square acre
surrounded by weeds and potato fields.
But the place offered a grim welcome to
the exhausted remnant of the "Final Solution"
who could barely see
past those barbed wire fences,
three of them in fact.
Concentric lines that scrawled a
crabbed and painful hieroglyphic
across the sky.
Not half a mile to west of Atlit,
the Mediterranean breaks
against a rocky shore.
And when the surf is high,
you can hear the stones hiss
and sigh in the tidal wash.
On the eastern horizon,
the foothills of the Carmel
reach heavenward,
in keeping with their name Karan El,
the vineyard of God.
Sometime the candles of the village
are visible in the high distance,
but not at this hours.
The night is too old for that.
It is cool in the mountains,
but hot and damp in Atlit.
The overhead lights throb
and buzz in the moist air,
heavy as a blanket,
nothing moves.
Even the sentries in their guard towers
are snoring,
lulled by the stillness and sapped
like their prisoners
by the cumulative weight of the heat.
There are no politics
in the waning hour of the night.
No regret,
no delay,
no waiting,
all of that will return with the sun,
and the waiting is worse than the heat.
Everyone who's locked up in Atlit
waits for an answer to the
same questions,
'When will I get out of here?
When will the past be over?'
There are only 170
inmates in Atlit tonight,
and fewer than 70 women in all.
It's the same lopsided ratio on
the chaotic roads of Poland and Germany,
France and Italy--
the same in the train stations,
and the displaced persons camps,
in queues for water,
identification cards,
shoes, information.
The same quotient too
in the creaking leaky boats
that secretly ferry survivors into
Palestine.
There is no mystery
to this arithmetic.
According to Nazi calculation,
males produced more value alive than dead,
if only marginally,
if only temporarily,
so they killed the women faster.
In barrack C,
the corrugated roof releases
the last degree of yesterday's sun,
warming the blouses and skirts
that hand like ghosts from the rafters.
There are burlap sacks suspended there as well,
lumpy with random rescued treasures--
photograph albums, books, candlesticks,
wooden bowls,
broken toys, tablecloths,
precious debris.
The narrow cots are lined up unevenly
against the naked wood walls.
The floor is littered with thin wool blankets
kicked aside in the heat.
A baby crib stand
empty in the corner.
In Haifa,
the lights are burning in the bakeries
where the bread rises and the workers
pour coffee and light cigarettes.
On the kibbutz,
among the pine trees high in the Carmel,
Darien are rubbing their eyes
and pulling on their boots.
In Atlit, the women sleep,
nothing disturbs them.
No one notices the soft stirring
of a breeze--
the blessing of the last
and gentlest chapter of this day.
It would be a kindness to prolong
this peace and let them rest a bit longer,
but the darkness is already heavy
with the gathering light.
The birds have no choice
but to announce the dawn.
Eyes begin to open."
And then we enter the world
for a bit of Atlit
and four, four young women in particular.
Atlit, in what still remains in Atlit,
which is I said is a tourist attraction
an education center,
mostly for Israeli kids but also Americans
who are coming through on one
of these particular historical tours.
And one of the buildings that's still standing
in addition to some of the barracks
is this giant kind of hangar-like place
which is called the 'delousing shed'
by the inmates,
and that's what I call it in the book.
And it's this - it's an enormous space
which scared the living daylights
out of people
because as they walked towards the front doors,
there were these giant machines to steam
people's clothes to get the lice off of them,
and they were exactly the same make and model
as the machines in some
of the concentration camps.
So people who had been through that saw this
and fainted and screamed and thought
they were going to be killed.
And no matter how much
reassurance people could give them
there was this tremendous dissonance between
what they were seeing and remembering
and then what they were being told--
even by people who spoke in their own language
and were trying to reassure them.
But in this big space now
where you can still see the showers
where people were sent to take showers--
they were full of lice
and they were filthy after being,
most of them had come over on boats
in crowded ancient creaking leaky boats.
So they had to be cleaned and deloused
and given new clothes.
But right now this also still--
it's a giant empty space
with pictures all over the walls
from the early days-- from the 1940's,
from 1944, 45, 46.
And there are pictures of a lot
of young men with their shirts off,
with their arms around each other dancing
and mugging for the cameras.
Very hot, in this place,
especially in the summer.
And there are fewer girls
as I mentioned in this prologue.
And some of the women,
the pictures of women are like sort of standing
like this with their faces very closed.
They're not mugging for the camera.
And I was really intrigued
by what those stories were like.
So my book tells the story
in particular of four women,
from four very different experiences,
only one of whom was
a concentration camp survivor.
The others were in hiding.
One of them is actually a partisan fighter,
and what their experiences
were like during the war.
So it's from four very different directions.
Because there is not just one holocaust story;
there is not just one arrival in Israel story;
there are multiple stories.
And over the course of this,
of actually over a summer--
it starts in August and ends in October--
these four women
become friends in a kind of way,
become family to each other in a kind of way
because they are all essentially orphans.
So they are forced to learn
one another's language pretty quickly
and make alliances in order to sort
of come back to life after the horrors
that they had been through in Europe.
I'm gonna stop and invite questions.
I can keep talking for a long time,
but I'd much rather interact. Yeah?
>> I'd love to hear more about
how you did the character research.
Anita: Character research?
female: Yeah.
Anita: Again, I never know how to answer that.
Because I knew pretty early on
that I didn't just want one protagonist,
I wanted to tell it
from multiple points of view.
Because I know that,
even in my own family,
the people who'd been
through the experiences of the war,
their temperament,
their family constellation
and fate and luck--
just--, people react differently.
So some people are horribly bitter
for the rest of their lives,
and some people become remarkably forgiving.
And why?
Why does that happen?
So I was sort of curious to explore that.
So there are four characters
from different countries,
from different kind of
socio-economic backgrounds.
And so, once I sort of set them up--
and what was really important to me
was to come up with their names
and locate where they were from.
And then I sort of started
to imagine and invent who they are.
And in my process,
as I write, I get to know them.
Then as I revise,
I really get to know them.
So, one of the characters,
Teddy-- her name came to me,
Teddy Pastore who grew up
in Amsterdam--
came to me very early on.
Some of the other characters names
changed like a year into it.
And then they sort of settled
and it was like that's the right name.
Names are really hard,
and really important.
So I did research about the Jewish community
in Amsterdam,
so I got a little bit of background in addition
to what everybody know about Anne Frank.
And I did a lot of reading,
and I also interviewed people,
a handful of people who had been in Atlit
when they were very young,
like teenagers,
like 14, 15 years old
who had come over after the war
and are now in their 70's remembering back.
And I also,
I hired somebody who
translated a bunch of,
very short kind of remembrances
of what it had been like in Atlit
in order to move forward.
One of the really interesting things about,
that I learned doing research
for this book was that
nobody talked about the holocaust
until about 1965 during the Eichmann trials
to a broadcast internationally.
And this was-- Eichmann was one
of the architects of the Final Solution
of the slaughter of so many millions
of people in Europe.
And it was broadcast internationally
and sort of opened the floodgates.
And people who'd been through
those years in Europe started to talk
and be interviewed and people
started to ask questions.
But until then,
there was this real
reluctance to talk about it.
There was a tremendous
amount of guilt and shame.
Why did I survive?
Why did my sister not survive?
And then for people
who hadn't been there,
'Why didn't I do more?
Why didn't I stop this from happening?
How could this have happened?'
So there was this sort of conspiracy
of silence through all this.
So until pretty recently,
people who had been though this,
people who had landed in Atlit,
they weren't so keen to talk
about their experiences.
So by the time they got,
they started to do world histories
and stuff like that,
a lot of them had died and
some of them had forgotten a lot
or just didn't want to talk
about it anymore.
So that's the challenge.
>> I would be an aspiring writer
if Google didn't work me so hard.
[laughter]
>> Sidebar.
So I'm curious about your process
when you write.
Do you start with just like a theme
and then you build up to an outline?
Or do you just sort of start writing and see
where that story goes organically from there?
Anita: Yes.
[Laughter]
Anita: I usually-- when I--
I've written three novels
and I'm about to start a fourth one
and I still feel like very much a journeyman.
I sort of learn how to do it
again every single time I write.
I was a non-fiction writer
for many many years.
I'm pretty
comfortable with that.
I know how to do that.
Fictions always [Small scream]
when I do it.
But I usually have a
beginning and an ending.
Sort of a-- you know sort of a--
the parenthesis of the story.
I kind of know where it's going.
That doesn't mean I know exactly
what it's gonna look like.
So,
every single time I've tried,
I've sort of-- I know
where I'm starting from.
I have some kind of a plot line
which also might change along the way.
But there's,
there's a beginning line and
the end line and the dead line.
And having been a journalist
for a long time,
I don't know how anybody does
this without that kind of training
that you have to meet your deadlines.
'Cause people work on novels for
20 years and they never finish them.
But that would drive me crazy.
So, I know that much.
I sometimes know about the
main characters a little bit.
So once I decided on
these four characters,
there's a bunch of other people
who are important in the book as well.
Sometimes they develop more into
becoming major minor characters,
sometimes they fade away completely.
And then I start doing research.
Even in the contemporary novel
that I wrote,
I had to do a lot of research.
And that feeds the writing
a lot for me.
Because the more I learn about
any given period of history,
or the climate or the food.
I'm a big-- I'm very interested
in the tactile stuff--
what people are eating and wearing
and how life is organized
and how old are you
when you get married.
And how many kids do
people generally have.
All of that kind of helps me
give shape to what I'm doing.
So I do research while I'm writing,
pretty much through the first draft.
Although I'll start with a lot of research,
but then I'll get started.
Otherwise I can just sort of get seduced
by learning more and more
about any given period.
And nobody really wants to know
everything you learned
which is a lot of research so you have
to leave a lot outside of it.
It's hard to write and have a real job
at the same time.
It's really challenging.
And if you're interested in doing it,
I think you need either a writing class
or a writing group
where other people are waiting
to see what you write.
'Cause it's really lonely otherwise,
and it's very easy to just say,
'I'm too tired.
I have laundry to do', whatever.
[laughter]
Whatever you need to do.
female: Do you ever web your characters
to create names?
Anita: Web them?
female: Like kind of put the images
of what the person is
to fill them out as a person?
Anita: No I don't actually.
That's the more organic part of what I do.
They sort of develop
as I'm writing on the page.
And then,
I have never written a book
without a computer.
I don't know how people
did that beforehand.
So it's very easy to go back--
female: Right.
Anita: --and revise and just sort of
search and change
everybody's name once.
[laughter]
Once you made it,
then not a blonde,
no no no,
you can change that back.
But no I don't.
And I know that's a writing exercise
that a lot of people are given.
There's that sort of ,
here's the character, what does she look like,
what's her back story,
who's her father, what did he do--
sort of to map out--
but I've never taken a creative writing class.
I was a journalist for a long time,
and I didn't take any journalism classes either.
And sort of learned,
I had great editors as a journalist
and learned by doing on the job.
female: What was the most interesting story
you heard while interviewing people early?
Or the most fascinating moment
you had throughout that process?
Anita: Well I think they all took place
while I was in these very intense little trips
when I was there.
I had two kind of business trips
and I spent an extra day
working on the book while I was there.
And so one, one of them actually,
if you read the book,
the epilogue of the book is fictional,
but it takes place in the room
that I describe with the gentlemen
who looks very much the person I describe
and that was a very powerful experience.
And he-- his story doesn't
really figure in here.
But he, he was Romanian.
He went back and forth
during the war and after the war
to try to rescue people and bring people
from Romania to Palestine,
to get them out.
And he was just a remarkably sweet and strong
and at that point very old and sick
at the same time, personal.
So it was really--
I felt like I was meeting somebody out of
another chapter of history in a lot of ways.
So that was very powerful.
And I remember also another trip
hiking around the mountains
'cause-- so the-
as I described Atlit as near the coast.
But it's not far up to the mountains,
so you actually can walk.
And they marched people up the mountains
in the dark of the moon,
which is kind of crazy.
Women and children without enough shoes
and stuff like that.
So we, I went there,
and the people who work at Atlit--
the director and the oral historian
who's collecting material
of the story in the camp.
So we were, we didn't walk it,
we drove part of the way and we walked
part of the way and had a picnic.
Everyone feeds you a lot there.
So I asked them a question.
And I had a translator with me too
'cause some had some English,
I have like no Hebrew.
So I asked a question about
whether it was possible,
whether it could have unfolded
the way I was imagining it.
So they talked to each other back and forth
for a good three minutes solidly debating
back and forth.
And then they turned
to me and said "yes".
[laughter]
So I remember that, very vividly.
They decided I could tell it that way.
The book just came out in
Hebrew a couple of weeks ago.
It's #2 on the best seller list in Israel
so that's very nice.
female: How do you separate yourself
emotionally when you're writing
about something so heavy?
And how do you keep that
from really inhibiting your personal life
because I can imagine
that's very difficult to write about it
and then go out
for dinner or meet friends?
Or do you not, I mean - does it...
Anita: No I do have a life.
female: does it flow over?
Anita: No it's--
I don't think I was a lot of fun to live with
in the last couple of years.
And, it was challenging.
And there were some days that
were really harder than other days.
But it's work.
It's like I would work
and it would spill over.
But I can to some extent segregate that part
of my work life and my emotional life that way.
I don't know if that's a good thing
or a bad thing.
But otherwise it would have been impossible.
I certainly don't
want to do it again.
I mean I certainly don't
want to revisit this period.
It was hard, it was really hard.
So,
whenever I've had to write really a violent
scene or a really painful scene of loss,
it lingers.
And that week, especially the week of--
and those, since those parts tend
to come later in a book,
I think I'm ready,
like there's been a
warm-up before that.
So I'm ready for it,
and it takes less time to write later.
The earlier parts of the book
take longer to write.
They just get rewritten over
and over and over again.
By the time I hit halfway through,
I sort of know what I'm doing
and I'm writing faster.
So it's, so I'm not quite living in it
quite as intensely.
It's really interesting to have these Q & A's
because sometimes I don't know
that until I just said that out loud.
[laughter]
Anita: I didn't realize that,
that that was my process.
female: So how did you move
from non-fiction to fiction?
Anita: How did I move
I needed a challenge.
I was kind of bored.
And so I actually thought
about getting a real job,
but I couldn't do it,
I had been self employed for too long.
So, I actually did some interviewing
and thought no,
I can't work for anyone else.
So I thought I would try writing a novel.
And no one was waiting for it.
I did not get a contract.
It was my little hobby,
but I also gave myself a deadline
'cause I didn't want to be one of those people
who's writing a novel for 15 years.
So I-- that was 'The Book of Dena'
when I was working on it -
it turned into 'The Red Tent'.
And it was really hard. It was a challenge,
I'd never done it before.
But I'm someone who's always read novels.
I was an English major and a Comp Lit major.
So reading novels is-- I can't remember
a time I didn't read them.
So--
and I had a very good friend who was
an editor who said, "Well it does translate,
but the skills you have as
a non-fiction writer do,
many of them anyway,
do translate into writing fiction."
And I had written a lot of first person stuff.
I had written columns for the Boston Globe
magazine and other national magazines, so.
I was used to writing in a variety
of different styles
and that sort of straight
answer in fifteen questions.
'Cause I was a feature writer,
so I had to write humor as
well as really heavy stuff.
So, I gave it a shot.
And I tried to sell it and I tried
to get an agent interested in it.
And nobody wanted to see it
until it was finished.
And then I very luckily found somebody
who wanted to publish it.
And that's how,
it was sort of a transition.
And it's not like I had this inspiration
and I had to do it.
It was like I really needed to shake up
my writing career and my writing mind.
So that's why I started.
And if I hadn't been as successful
as I was with the first one,
I don't know if I would have written
another one.
I certainly wouldn't have had the option
to do pretty much what I wanted to do.
I was really very lucky.
female: What sources do you draw
from in creating
like the personalities of your characters?
Do you think it's mostly from
the people you interview or do they--
do your characters reflect people
you actually know or yourself?
Or is it just like imagination?
Anita: Yes. All those things,
all those things.
I think certainly with this book,
these characters.
There's a couple of minor characters.
There's the cook who's actually
from Palestine.
She's a local person.
She's based very much on reading
that I did about what people in Palestine
and how they reacted to this flood
of immigrants
with these horrible stories and tattoos
on their arms.
And just how do you?
And so her reluctance
to talk to them,
to engage with them was based
on things that I've learned.
And then I sort of gave her
a personality around that.
The other characters are based
on somewhat on people I know,
somewhat on books that I read,
somewhat on interviews.
Not just the ones that I did personally,
but also pieces that, interviews that I read.
So it's a real combination
of different things.
So, it's all fodder.
For me anyway, fiction and non-fiction,
it's all kind of fodder.
male: So why this specific
point in history?
Because there's a lot
of very interesting,
very complicated,
very heavy stuff somewhere
between 45 and early 50's
I would say in the history of Israel
as the land and as the state.
And I've been on the Birthright tour
and they take you to various places
that leave a big mark sort of in different ways.
So why that specific place?
Why that specific story?
Anita: Well in large measures
because I didn't know and
I knew that nobody else knew it
certainly in my world.
I think a lot of Israelis know it
because it's sort of part of the story of--
the triumphal story of the army,
the Palmach, the pre-army.
The great success.
Nobody was-- all the inmates got taken
out safely and they got away with it.
There was only one casualty,
it was considered a huge success.
But my novels in particular always
try to tell the stories that are untold.
So they tend to focus on women's stories
because they tend to be under told.
Not so much in 'Dogtown' which
includes a bigger cast of characters.
So looking at those pictures of the guys
mugging and smiling at the camera
and the women standing sort of like this
and looking not at the camera
made me wonder what their experience
was like.
So there was that.
And also the fact that I liked the idea that I
could tell a story that nobody had heard before.
There are zillions of great stories like that,
but this is the one that got thrown into my lap.
So it's really very much serendipity
why I write what I write.
It's when I stumble across
a story that I think,
"Oh, nobody knows this,
I didn't know this and
because I didn't know it,
it means I'm excited about doing
the research to find out more about it."
So it's a very narrow view
of that year of that time.
And since it's told mostly
through these characters,
they can't know everything.
They don't know all the
politics swirling around them.
They don't know about the whole
military complex building up to fight.
And they barely are aware of the presence
of the Arab community around them as well.
So they're focused on surviving.
And they're thrown into this place.
And for me in a way,
the book is really about how do you live
through unspeakable horror and continue?
How do you embrace life?
How do you keep going?
How do you manage all of that?
So spending a few years thinking
about and writing is one thing,
but how do you live
through horrible losses?
And it's not just limited to the holocaust.
People whose families are wiped out in Haiti.
How are those people going to move forward?
Build families and communities, start over.
How do you start over again?
And that was for me the really
interesting question I wanted
to explore it with these characters.
female: Were there any points in the three
years that you were really stumped,
that you really struggled with
a piece of the story
and you didn't know which way
you wanted to take it?
Anita: There were a lot of
days I didn't want to do it.
So, but no I,
since I had the arc of the story and this rescue
and that was going to happen in the book.
And that's not giving anything away, really.
The things that there are to be given away
are about what happens to the people
and what their back stories are.
I had that trajectory to move forward.
It was just the hard part was was really
thinking about what they'd been through.
And figuring out how each character was
going to deal with that in her own way.
So that-- those were the sticking points.
But unlike in some of the other stuff
I've written where I really didn't know
which way to
turn I did have a sort of line.
I knew sort of when
it was gonna end.
Although I had a different ending
and a different sort of post script in mind
when I was working on it.
Didn't work out though.
But by then you trust it.
female: You're obviously very organized
and goal oriented with deadlines
and getting to that and obviously crunching
out 15 or more giant works.
But I'm wondering were there any along the way
that fell to the wayside and you've given up on?
Anita: No, no.
I have gotten a contract for every book
that I've ever written, except for 'The Red Tent'.
So no.
[laughter]
female: I have never ever failed.
Anita: No no I failed a lot, I failed a lot,
but the books,
it's like it's the job right?
And having written for newspapers
and magazines for a long time,
if you don't turn in you piece,
you don't get paid and you don't
get invited back to do it again.
So I'm pretty careful about only
doing books that I know that I can write.
That I have some faith that
I can finish in the allotted time.
So, I wouldn't sign on to do something
that I was really, uh oh,
I don't know what I'm getting myself into.
So by the time I've signed a contract,
I really have some sense
of the beginning and the end.
At least some of the characters
and what the point of,
why am I telling this story.
So that's all in place.
No, I fail all the time,
but not in this.
female: And now since you mentioned
you have a little bit more creative freedom,
you can just walk in and say,
"Here's the idea."
Or is there more selling you have to do?
Anita: Well I have to, no I don't just walk in,
I have to write something
and my agent walks in and says.
'Do you want this?'.
So, we'll see.
So far I've been able to do
pretty much what I've wanted to do.
Publishing is in a very
weird place right now.
And don't know, how many books
do you buy in a year?
Or how many books do
you download in a year?
So we don't really,
it's all up in the air
what's gonna happen.
I think with publishing with, publishing,
all print media is trying to
figure out what the next steps are.
male: So would you be opposed to
your books being available in Kindle?
Anita: They're all in Kindle,
they're all in Kindle.
I'm not opposed to them online.
And I own one and I
read it on airplanes.
I don't like it enough to not,
I love it on an airplane,
I really do.
And I feel very cool because
people come over and ask you.
But still it's getting
much more common.
But the payout is really complicated
for writers and publishers,
and if you spend three years on a book,
and it's downloaded for $7.99
and you get some tiny fraction of that,
it's the economics of
publishing are really what's,
the business model is really
what's up in the air.
People are writing more than ever before,
but getting paid for your work,
for creative work is kind of, nobody knows
how this is gonna shake down.
And having been a newspaper writer for
a long time too, even more so in journalism.
female: Do you ever get push backs
from your editors
who will read a couple of chapters and want
you to take something in a different direction?
And how do you deal with that?
Do you have to listen to them, or is it,
or do you have enough
clout that you can say,
'No, this is what I'm gonna do.' ?
Anita: I generally, I have a good working
relationships with my editor.
And editors,
my editors pretty uniformly
including magazines and books,
they want to make it a better book.
It's not like that they want to
change it just for the purpose of,
'I think I can tell the story
better than you can.'
So when they suggest a change,
or ask a question about where,
about what a character is saying
or where things are going
or the way that time is put together
in the story telling.
I take it seriously that they're really trying
to improve what I'm doing.
So I see it as a collaboration.
And there are times that I say,
'No this is really, this is the way I want to go.'
But generally,
especially if you get it
from more than one person,
you gotta take it seriously.
If nobody knows what
you're talking about here,
then it's time to take a look at it.
And I sometimes when I see books
that are this thick,
and I start reading them I think,
boy this person really did not,
nobody tried to edit or the writer didn't
want to hear about editing.
So I think editing is good, I like editing.
[Laughter]
It feels good.
If it's a respectful relationship,
it's really terrific.
female: Did you mention that you
have another book in the works?
And can you share anything?
Anita: I just, I mean like yesterday
sent the proposal to my agent
to have it given to the publisher.
It's set on American soil
and it would probably be a,
I'm not gonna tell you,
it's not ready yet. [laughter]
Anita: Soon, so I hafta,
I'm waiting to hear from them.
But it's not,
it's an American story.
female: So you mentioned that
this book was translated in Hebrew.
And I'm assuming other books
of your have been translated.
I've always been really curious,
what is the process like to have your work
translated into another language?
Especially if you don't speak it
to like maintain the integrity of the book?
Anita: You know, it's out of my hand.
What happens is that publishers,
publishers from other countries
can buy the rights to translate and sell.
And they buy them through--
I mean I will get an e-mail that says,
"The Croations want to
translate this into Croat.
Is that okay, and they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars."
And it's really,
that's about what it is.
What am I gonna-- great,
I mean you just keep your fingers crossed
and hope that it's a decent translation.
I actually met the Israeli
woman who translates.
She's translated all four
of my novels now.
And she's really lovely,
and people tell me
she's a good translator, but...
female: So you don't really have that, they don't
e-mail you and they're like, "Hey is this?"
Anita: No I do get questions.
So like really interesting,
she e-mailed me.
If they don't know
what something is.
She didn't know what a 'GI' was.
And I thought wow I thought,
"God, I thought the whole world knew
what GI's were."
General enlisted,
General Infantry during the way.
But that was not a term
she was familiar with.
Soldiers, she knew soldiers.
So in all of them,
it's really fun to get
questions like that.
What is really not is really idiosyncratic
to American English in particular.
I don't even know that a British person
would know that right now.
In the 40's everybody
must have known what a GI was,
'cause it was in newspapers everywhere.
female: I'm wondering if you draw
on your own experiences
to develop the emotional content
of your characters.
And in particular as a mother
and a daughter,
how you address the kind of orphaned
nature of these four characters?
Anita: Oh sure, I mean my emotional
life is in here.
And I think the emotional life
of all my friends and relatives as well.
When I was writing a column
for the Boston Globe,
it was like all my friends
were like on alert.
You know, "Are you gonna use this?"
But I use everything.
So, so certainly I think all writers are mining
their own emotional lives and histories
for what they write.
And they can pretend that they
aren't but that's not true. [laughter]
There's no way around it.
Yes?
female: I am an avid reader,
not a writer,
and I never want the books to end
if it's a good story, if it's a good character.
How do you know where to end?
Anita: You know,
it's really clear when it's an end
for me 'cause I'm really looking for,
I really believe in that kind of,
I don't know the musical term,
but there's sort of a resolution
at the end of a symphony.
It's like TAH DAH.
And Beethoven writes 20 of them
at the end of one of those.
But there's a resolution,
there's almost a musical resolution
that the hand comes off the piano keys
and it's, that's the last note.
A lot of people with this book have said,
'It's too short and I want more
and I want the sequel.'
And that's good,
I mean leaving them wanting
more is always a good thing.
Beginning and endings are really hard.
Beginnings are really super hard
and endings are very hard too
but by then at least I sort of know
what the melody is
so I know where and how I want
to do the resolution.
Books that end badly are really frustrating.
I mean as a reader to it's like,
what happened.
I want things,
not everything has to be
tied up in neat little knots.
You don't have to know
what happens to everybody.
But there has to be some resolution,
and for me there has to be
some kind of redemption.
Certainly in what I write.
And I prefer books that have some kind
of modulated minor key major resolution.
It can't be like ugh,
I don't like books
that leave me completely flat,
novels anyway that leave me completely flat,
so I don't write novels that way.
I don't think, I mean this is not a happy book,
but not everybody is [ inaudible] at the end,
life goes on.
female: Who are some of
your favorite authors?
Anita: My favorite authors.
I love MFK Fisher who you
probably have never heard of.
She was a food writer for the New Yorker
and she wrote beautiful funny smart prose.
And I reread her books all the time.
And I'm a big poetry fan.
I read Naruta and Mary Oliver
and Billy Collins and Walt Whitman.
Fiction, I read sort of
what my friends tell me to read,
like everybody else I think.
So I think the last novel I read was The Help
which was at the top of the best seller list,
which I enjoyed very much.
One of the books that really changed
my life was 100 years of solitude
by Gabriel Garca Mrquez
which I read when I was in High-School.
I've read it many times since then.
Just, it was really new at the time,
and it continues to be new.
So if you haven't read that one,
the other ones are--
that one's just beautiful.
It's the first one,
I think it was his first novel,
I think he'd written shorter pieces, no?
male: No I think he had a couple.
Anita: Before, that was his big success?
male: That was his first big success,
the earlier stuff is very hard to read.
[laughter]
Anita: So I'm glad
I didn't read it.
'Cause that was-- I remember it
was a big success in the states to,
so I read that.
So I would recommend
that to anybody.
So yeah,
sort of like what people hand me
is what I read.
People that I trust is what I read.
Sometimes they're wrong,
and I don't like it.
But often they're right.
And I like reading what other people
are reading in a given moment.
I read my first Trollope
actually a couple of months ago.
I'd never read Trollope,
it was one of the early novelists.
It was fun, it was hard,
you had to slow down to read
that sort of thing.
I'm always trying new stuff.
I like to read internationally too.
male: Have you read Marquez's latest piece?
Anita: I don't, which is the latest one?
male: 'Memory of My Melancholy Whores"
I believe it was called.
Anita: Is that the autobiography?
>> No, not quite.
Anita: No, I couldn't get through
the autobiography, I really couldn't.
So no I didn't read that,
I sort of stopped, I have to say.
I read a lot for a long time,
but then I stopped.
So what are you reading?
[laughter]
female: Really?
Anita: Yeah.
female: Well I'm reading your book.
Anita: Yes yes, that's the right answer.
[laughter]
female: My book club recommended this.
Anita: Oh, you're in a club?
female: Yeah, which is good.
Recommend book clubs,
forces you to read
and creates deadlines.
female: Have any of your works been considered
to be translated into movies,
and is that something that you would consider?
I love 'The Red Tent',
like that could be a good movie.
Anita: It's been really interesting.
The book was optioned for a few
years when it first came out.
It takes such a big stack
of money to make a movie.
You can't begin to imagine.
It means a lot of backing and it means
a big star and it means, you know
on and on and on.
So, I'm not constitutionally opposed
to the idea of it,
but I dare you to think up a biblical movie
that is worth sitting through.
[laughter]
They're pretty bad.
I think actually
they're really bad.
Can you think of them?
female: No.
Anita: I mean, 'The Ten Commandments'
comes right to mind, right.
Have you seen that lately?
[laughter]
Right, at least twice a year or something.
People get so -
I would love if someone took
'The Red Tent' and sort of deconstructed it
and made it into something filmic.
And I know it's sort of cinematic,
but people get too pious about the bible
and they just worry too much.
And I think that's a problem.
And I really did not,
I didn't novelize the bible like
Thomas Mann did in the Joseph novels.
He wrote like this
whole series of novels.
So it's not faithful to the text
in a certain kind of way.
I fear that if somebody took 'The Red Tent'
and tried to make a movie out of it,
they would be faithful and that
would be the kiss of death.
It would be great if somebody
like Spike Jonez wanted to do it.
Somebody really wanted to take it
and make it their own vision.
It's also that there aren't enough
explosions in it to really make it a
To get the funding. [laughter]
Anita: So not yet.
I think this book is very cinematic actually.
It's got lots of nubile young women in it.
It's also got a military rescue.
But, we'll see if that happens.
female: [Inaudible] So I was told a long time ago
that if you're reading a new book,
read the last sentence
Anita: Ouch.
female: And that's no, just the sentence
and that's like a good indication
of if you're probably gonna
like the book or not.
Anita: Did you?
female: I did, the last sentence.
[laughter]
Anita: It's the first thing I always check.
female: But I was wondering if you have
any tidbits of advice like that.
Anita: No, I will give any book
about 50 pages,
but if I'm not in love with at least
somebody in those 50 pages,
I'll stop.
At some point in the last 10 years,
I just-- life is too short,
I'm not reading it if it
doesn't really grab me.
And that's including
some of the greats,
contemporary great writers.
It's just like I don't
like this writing,
I don't like the style of it,
and people who are very hot
aren't necessarily people who...
But that's okay.
I mean there should be lots of flavors
and lots of different styles.
But I stop after awhile.
male: What about non-fiction?
Anita: I like them, I read them.
male: But they're not necessarily
characters that you can like or not.
Anita: Oh, no, well if it's well written
and it's compelling,
I really enjoy non-fiction.
I'm reading a fair amount of history
again in preparation for this book
that I'm hoping to write.
And I enjoy that too.
So, last summer I loved the Julia Child
biography by her nephew.
If you saw 'Julie and Julia',
you should really read the book,
it's really fun.
Really nice writing, really non-fiction.
And I got to meet Julia Child
and talk to her,
so I could hear her voice when
she lived here many years ago.
So that was fun.
It was my last really fun non-fiction book.
The rest has been history,
but interesting.
So that's what I'm reading.
I'm up to here with
American history right now,
so that's why it's hard for me to reach out
for the novels that don't [inaudible].
male: You went in one of these camps,
and so what happens to you internally.
It seems like there were people
popping up on the shore all the time.
200 people in this camp.
It's going to be way too full,
in a day, a week, a month,
so they gotta do something.
They can't take them out,
the boat's gone.
Anita: Well what happens.
male: They essentially let them go.
Anita: They let them go.
male: They all tell the same story basically.
Anita: They do let them go,
for the most part in Atlit.
But what happened is
so many people started coming,
they built an enormous camp in Cyprus.
So that's if you saw the movie 'Exodus',
or read that book.
That's not a great book by the way,
a terrible book. [laughter]
Anita: It's a better movie than a book.
They took the dramatic part of it.
They built this enormous
internment camp in Cyprus.
And people were there for years.
And it was hot and miserable, and also,
for all of that there were millions,
there were many many marriages,
there were many children born.
People taught school to the children,
they taught music to the children.
So, they made life happen
in this incredibly hot miserable place.
So that's what happened to a lot of them.
I mean it was at relatively
[Inaudible] this whole coast line.
So a lot of people did get in and...
male: Yeah, like maybe catch one
in three or something.
Anita: Right, so the people
who were in camp.
And at least some of them
actually wound up having family,
so they got released to family.
If they were sick,
they got sent to hospitals.
Children in particular if they were orphans
would get sent to orphanages.
So the British were a real mixed bag
as occupiers.
They were both compassionate and jerks.
I mean, and it depended on the individual
as much as anything else.
But, they were-- I remember Barak
who gave this tour talking and saying,
"You gotta have, if your prison camp is gonna
be run by anybody, you want the British,
because they believe in rules."
male: So did the Germans?
Anita: Huh?
male: So did the Germans.
Anita: Well, in a different--
but they also believed
in the Geneva conventions
and that these were not prisoners,
these were in fact internees.
And they knew that they were.
And they were-- and there was a lot of guilt
among some of the British as well.
They were not all happy
about being put in this position.
There were anti-Semites who were very happy
So they were, they were just human beings
in ultimately an impossible situation.
As it still is to this very day.
male: So this seems like actually
the British had a fig leaf
and they made some treaty or something
and promised that they would stop immigration.
Anita: Right.
male: Clearly they can't.
Anita: They can't exactly.
male: And clearly they can't shoot them
at the water's edge,
or they're not prepared to.
Anita: They're not prepared to.
And at the same time they had to
keep the Arab population at the same saying,
"We are, we are enforcing these quotas."
male: They're making some show
of doing their best.
Anita: Right.
And they did their...
And then they opened Cyprus
which really was this big holding camp
which became an international embarrassment.
Because people got sick there
and people would die there, it was.
male: So many people in squalor.
Anita: Yes, too many people.
male: And you can't park them there forever.
Anita: Right, exactly. But they were there--
it felt like forever.
They were there for years.
In Atlit, people were there
for weeks or months.
In Cyprus they were stuck for a long time.
And it was an island,
it was hard to escape.
male: Whenever I think about it,
it just reminds me of
our own southern border.
There are people trying sneak
across in the dark of night.
Hope of a better life.
A community up here
if they can make it,
that they can thread right into.
And I mean some fraction they catch.
Of course we're not shooting them
at the water's edge either.
Anita: We're not shooting them.
male: But neither do we make it pleasant
enough that they are excited about.
I suspect actually that 9 out of
10 make it clean and clear over time.
Anita: Probably. Fewer now
because the economy is so bad.
But yeah, I think this is sort of
an international classic story
about trying to get into a place that you're
sort of not legally supposed to be part of.
And the world is more porous
than it's ever been before.
Or at borders anyway.
No matter what we try.
female: We're just about out of time.
Thank you so much for coming,
this is wonderful.
Anita: Thank You.
[applause]